[Musique]
la tuer
salut les amis je suis toujours à
ajaccio je joue ce soir mais là je suis
un peu perdue donc je vais demander aux
locaux de de m'aider excusez moi
mademoiselle de vous un portier à l'eau
s'il vous plaît pardon j'aimerais savoir
si vous connaissez le palatine eu mais
je vous connais pas ah non vous êtes
malade in latine eu mon palatine
ces demandes vont ressembler à cette
chanteuse la poésie
j'arrive
toi jennifer non ça creuse
voilà oui c'est ce soir à latin-jazz
quand même mais super mais simplement
des petits crois qu'elle est enceinte
encore je fais pas dire
[Musique]
grieco crédit
tout est noir
tient
là tu
et là
non je n'ai pas d'annoncé à nager club à
paris j'ai cru que ah bah oui vous vous
portez les mêmes trucs aussi basse
arrive tout faire avec ce pardon je suis
désolé car il est riche idée